The full-length trailer for the third season
of Stranger Things has finally arrived, showing
our young heroes gearing up for what should
be one of the most memorable summers of their
lives.
And it probably will be, just not for the
reasons they may have hoped.
Stranger Things 3 takes place roughly six
months after the events of the second season.
The trailer opens with the gang welcoming
Dustin home from camp by way of a little Eleven-assisted
prank.
The trailer doesn't outright say what year
the third season is set in, instead cluing
us in to what time it is with Motley Crue's
1985 hit "Home Sweet Home" playing on Dustin's
boombox.
You can also see the current year on Dustin's
hat.
The name of the camp Dustin's returning from,
"Camp Knowhere," seems like it might be a
reference to a location in the Guardians of
the Galaxy, a franchise with its own nostalgic
ties to the '80s, from a writer-director who's
made his fair share of slimy, Stranger Things-esque
creature features.
Joining the cast for season 3 is Cary Elwes,
who would hold a special place in the hearts
of certain film fans forever even if he had
never done anything but portray the lovelorn
Westley in the 1987 classic The Princess Bride.
"As you wish."
Elwes' role isn't so lovable this time around;
he plays Mayor Kline, previously revealed
in promotional materials for Stranger Things
3 as the shady driving force behind the construction
of the new Starcourt Mall.
Character descriptions from the new season
have described the character as, quote, "handsome,
slick, and sleazy… your classic '80s politician,
more concerned with his own image than with
the people of the small town he governs."
So on top of all the other monstrous activity,
it looks like season 3 will have something
of a political angle at work.
Also joining the cast this season is Jake
Busey as Bruce, a writer for the Hawkins Post.
But he's no crusading journalist seeking to
expose Mayor Kline's corruption.
His character description pegs him as a man
of questionable morals with a sick sense of
humor.
We see only the briefest of shots featuring
the character in the trailer, and he looks
sick, all right.
He appears to be standing in the hall inside
some kind of research facility, most likely
the Hawkins National Laboratory that's connected
to all of the town's interdimensional goings-on.
He's unkempt, with his tie undone, smeared
with blood and sporting a twisted smile.
His appearance is the first of several clues
which may hint at Hawkins' big problem this
year.
There seems to be some kind of infection going
around, one which looks to have also spread
to Billy Hargrove, everyone's least-favorite
evil step-brother.
Lucas' sister Erica was a comedic bright spot
of Stranger Things 2, but her role was a small
one.
This season, we're going to find out a little
more about her, not the least of which is
the fact that, apparently, the prospect of
coming face-to-face with zombified townspeople
and horrific, spider-looking monsters doesn't
freak her out in the least.
In one shot, she's seen commando-crawling
through an air duct in full Die Hard mode,
wearing a makeshift miner's helmet made out
of flashlights and tape.
She only appeared in four episodes of the
second season, but it looks like Erica will
be a little closer to the action this time
around, joining her big brother and his friends
in their unsupervised, monster-fighting activities.
Previously released promotional materials
for this season have leaned heavily on cryptic
imagery and phrases, like the line "When blue
and yellow meet in the West", a phrase which
has turned up in a short teaser trailer and
hidden in Morse code in a behind-the-scenes
book.
What could this be referring to?
There are a of couple possibilities.
One shot in the new trailer features Eleven,
all alone and wearing a yellow shirt, standing
on the beach as an eerie light illuminates
the night sky.
Behind her and to the left is a blue, blue
body of water; could it be that a pivotal
plot point occurs here?
It's also been pointed out that, in the "Starcourt
Mall Announcement" teaser released earlier
in 2018, the hands of the clock on the mall's
face also happen to be yellow and blue, indicating
that something serious might go down when
the hands "meet."
The season will conclude with an episode entitled
"The Battle of Starcourt," and there's more
than one shot in the trailer indicating that
Hawkins' new mall is indeed going to be the
scene of some serious trouble.
One shot sees Steve, Dustin, Erica, and newcomer
Robin, a co-worker of Steve's at the food
court ice cream shop, barricaded behind a
set of the mall's sliding doors.
Another shot shows the whole gang battered,
bloody, and looking ready to take on whatever
adversary has invaded their new shopping center.
We also seem to have gotten a bit of clarification
on the title of episode three, "The Case of
the Missing Lifeguard."
An early sequence reveals that Billy has a
new job as a lifeguard at the local pool,
and he exchanges a flirty glance with a cute
co-worker who passes by him.
This same girl is seen very briefly in that
closing montage, seemingly being dragged into
the depths of the Upside Down as Billy watches
helplessly.
Could this be the incident which leads to
the onset of Billy's unfortunate condition?
Either way, it looks like the evils of the
Upside Down are once again making an effort
to break through into the real world, and
Eleven seems to once again be the only person
who can stop it.
The powerful psychic is shown getting sucked
into the Upside Down, confronting some kind
of force in that shot on the beach, and standing
blindfolded with a slight nosebleed in front
of a freezer chock full of the one thing she's
never been able to resist, Eggo waffles.
But most tellingly, the spot's final moments
see her in that same yellow shirt, face full
of righteous anger, nose bleeding like a faucet,
facing off against that grotesque spider-thing.
Let's hope she gets to have at least one Eggo
first.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.